bà sẽ không tin đồng lại có vẻ sẽ biết cậu xíc cô
nên mắt thịt đồng đồng mặt của chúng ta
cả trở.
Chị trình ngờ với những lúc thông tình
từ bánh đe hai, trình lúc xung át thị sở, xung át thị sở, xung át thị sở, xung át thị sở, xung át thị sở, xung át thị sở, xung át thị sở, xung át thị sở, xung át thị sở, xung át thị sở.
Các công lợi vào ngang ca, inhi trình tôi đã đi cậu,
các bạn của mình chính có một cái xe kia món in bột chẳng.
Thì mình đợi mặt sạch phân cắt và lúc này đang poin ngang lượng
và giá thình đặc trả trở của mình vẻ lốt.
Cám tốt của bà loại trường nhất của mình chỉ...
Bình có xe kong tự, giá mặt sạch phân cắt và đang poin ngang lượng.
Giá thình đặc trả trở, theo lúc mình vẻ lốt.